a good sign in the fight against the
pandemic new guidance expected today on
wearing masks
the cdc guidelines will focus on what
it's safe to do
outdoors especially if you've already
been vaccinated
wishing is at the white house with more
on the story wiza good morning to you
president biden
is expected to speak today on the state
of the pandemic so what do you know what
have you heard about this new guidance
good morning gail federal official tells
us that the language is not final but
the updated guidelines will stem from
one key factor whether somebody is
vaccinated or not
the recommendations will outline what
someone should and
should not do if they are vaccinated
when they're outside like whether they
should wear a mask
we also expect some clarification around
protocols in health care settings
the current cdc guidance acknowledges
that masks may not be
necessary when you are outside by
yourself away from others or with people
who live in your household but advises
to follow mask
mandates while out in public studies
identified by the journal of infectious
diseases found less than 10 percent of
covet infections
occurred outdoors white house officials
have said they do not believe it's the
government's place to mandate vaccines
this approach appears to be grounded in
giving people incentives to get
vaccinated
in other words here are all the things
you did before covert that you can do
again if you get vaccinated on his first
full day in office
president biden asked every american to
mask
up for his first 100 days and that is
something he could revisit
when he delivers remarks about the
pandemic later this afternoon
tony all right weeja thank you very much